histoire français ou management cinq
épreuves attendent perrine plus qu'une
semaine pour réviser avant de passer son
bac pro esthétique et même si cela ne
fait que quelques jours qu'elle a
commencé le planning est déjà chargé je
vais réviser un petit peu le matin
forcément une matière une première
matière une matière dont j'ai pas moins
besoin de réviser comme l'histoire géo
je suis plus tôt à l'aise donc ça va et
après l'après midi j'ai surtout bossé
les grosses épreuves celle de par
exemple d'esthétique et celle de vente
où je fais c'est un peu plus difficile
du coup j'ai plus beau c'est celle ci
l'après-midi le stress commence à monter
j'avoue mais ça va d'après je sais que
je j'ai révisé tout au long de l'année
mais cours donc je me dis que ça ça va
vous êtes elle est très très stressé
alors là ça va mais on je pense que cinq
jours avant ça va monter petit à petit
ça va monter petit à petit est en fait
la veille faudra pas lui adresser la
parole
un stress que perrine arrive quand même
à maîtriser sa méthode accompagner ces
révisions de musique ou d'une série faut
bien m'occuper en même temps enfin je
préfère faire plusieurs choses en même
temps parce que sinon je suis pas motivé
pour faire mais fisher fait voilà ça me
permet de me motiver de mettre de la
musique ce fait des fiches tout
simplement
après moi je sais que je relis aussi
beaucoup mes cours les définitions
surtout les mots importants
après si une phrase qui me paraît très
importante je vais l'a marqué mais après
c'est pour la sauce des abréviations
voilà c'est les choses les plus
importantes face à l'un d'eux exactement
car en cours parce que chien ça sert à
rien de recopier comme près de 700 mille
candidats en france perrine est attendu
jeudi 15 juin pour la première épreuve
c'est la première fois qu'elle passe cet
examen et elle espère bien la dernière